well joining me in the studio now is the
shadow international trade secretary
Barry Gardner hello thanks for being
with us
nice morning now you're not going to
thank me for this but I feel that we are
going to start with the polls that
around in today's news Athens because
they don't make pretty reading for your
party we can have a look at one of them
this is the comrade Sunday mirror poll
50% for the Conservatives I mean that is
the highest percentage that any party
since 2002 the highest with the
Conservatives since 1991 I mean look at
this it's going to be a bloodbath isn't
it well let flick-on up and you'll see
the the sunday mail the mail on Sunday
and they're saying that the Tory lead
has halved in the latest poll from last
night to 11 points now look Sophie I'm
surprised too celebrating an 11-point I
read for the corners
I'm not what I'm saying I'm trying to
show you that there's a fluctuation in
what the polls are saying between a 25%
and an 11% and you know I think that we
have a lot of ground to cover over the
next six or seven weeks and I'm very
confident that when people start looking
not at what the polls are saying but
what the policies of each of the parties
are they're then going to say well
actually I don't trust the Tories on tax
because I've seen what Philip Hammond
wanted to do in raising n I see in the
budget they're refusing to abide by
their promise that they made in 2015 in
their manifesto that they wouldn't raise
and national insurance contribution
they're refusing to say that they won't
put up v80 again and actually philip
hammond when he was last week at the IMF
in Washington he said all Chancellor's
would like greater flexibility on tax
it's very clear they're abandoning those
promises and you know I think the
electorate are going to look at that
they're going to say well why is it
they're abandoning the triple lock on
pensions you know this is this is
something that people are deeply worried
about because you know we need to give
elderly people dignity and security in
retirement I'm committed to that we were
Tories one we will come on to policy
later shortened to keep up
but at the same time though if you polls
the policy labor would do quite well if
you just look at the policies in
isolation but the problem is people just
don't trust you they don't believe you
and you're talking about The Mail on
Sunday poll which actually compares two
different polls so it's very difficult
to draw too much onto that Mel on Sunday
poll and of course we don't trust polls
but at the same time the polls have
never been this wrong have they I mean
by all accounts you're heading for
crashing to feature I tell you when they
were last this wrong okay when Donald
Trump won the right on the white house
and when Jeremy Corbyn won the
leadership of the Labour Party that's
when they will last this wrong and
actually it was holes betting markets
very well betting markets and there and
the polls those who thought who thought
two years ago that jeremy corn would
become the leader of the Labour Party
and when you talk about trust
well the fat Pollock a look at so they
started I think about it wasn't it when
the battles of labour members started to
enjoy that he would let's be clear on
trust this is somebody who is leading
the Labour Party now who has been
absolutely consistent over years many
people dislike his constancy
his consistency and but he's been
absolutely consistent he's never said
one thing and then gone against it he's
not that sort of person
and if you look at what Theresa May is
doing within two years of having
promised things on her manifesto at the
last general election where she was a
senior member of the of the cabinet as
Home Secretary and she's now rowing back
on all the promises she's made that's
why she's called this election because
she wants to be able to get rid of those
promises and actually be freed up she
thinks here's a political opportunity to
be freed up to do what I like and it's
tough what she's going to bring in is
going to be hard for British people it's
going to be hard for all our businesses
in negotiating a hard brexit because
that's what she's about and this is
going to be really really difficult for
Britain if she gets the mandate that she
wants now there's one thing that I do
want to ask you about cos and slightly
confused because back in 20 2008 you
called for Gordon Brown to resign and
call a leadership contest because this
is your words at the time
the public has stopped listening to him
in 2008
gosh - huh girls sure my beard was gosh
good divergent active flow and like
nobody I'm shocked by the photographs
goodness me you're much smarter now
berry don't worry and the public has
stopped listening to gone brown you said
he was should resign the polls show that
the public has stopped listening to
Jeremy Corbyn so why aren't you calling
for him to resign is it just cuz you got
a better job this time they play the
rest of my quote there I said it was
because he had shown complete
vacillation complete vacillation I mean
if you if you run the rest of that quote
you'll see all the points that I made he
had said that he was going to set out
his case to the British public that's
why he hadn't called the general
election a year previously and and he
didn't and he had vacillated on policies
at that time I wanted clear direction
and strong leadership and he wasn't
offering it at that point I have to say
six months later when it came to the
global financial crisis and resolving
that in the g20 in London he was
brilliant he I mean he he suddenly
became Superman and he did a fantastic
job there but at the point that I I
called for him to go it was because
actually I think there had been a year
of real crisis perhaps personal crisis
but but also in terms of just not
knowing what he wanted to do being in
number 10 Jeremy Corbyn knows that very
clearly he's absolutely clear about what
he wants to do in number 10 and what he
query wants this country to go okay
loyal response there - Jeremy Corbyn now
I'm keen to talk about your big policy
announcement today which is this new
bank holidays for new bank holiday so
things got so bad now you're bribing
boaters with the idea of more time of
work I don't I don't think it's about
bribing voters at all and look our
foreign nations in the United Kingdom
have really never been quite as divided
as we are at the moment
and I think it's great that in Scotland
and Northern Ireland and Wales they
should be celebrating the 23rd of April
which by the way I do saving the you
today holidays not only Shakespeare's
bestie but but since George's and it's
also my brother's birthday and I have to
apologize on TV if I may that I haven't
sent him a birthday card with the
election last week but I will get round
to it I promise but it's great that
we're actually talking about celebrating
those things which bring us together and
and having holidays a good way of doing
that we have less holidays than anybody
else in the g20 this would only take us
up to the g20 average of holidays 12 a
year we have less than France we've less
than Germany we with half as many as
Japan which is as 16 public holidays
each year and yet they are the third
largest economy in the world and of
course we can do this and it and it
won't actually have to impact and affect
our productivity now of course you can
only do this if you get somewhere near
power I mean that's the same with your
own brief shadow international trade
when Donald Trump they're warning that
Britain will be put back to the back of
the queue when it comes to the trade
deals that the EU would be prioritised
yes to have any impact on us you're
gonna have to be in power on look it
isn't that extraordinary
now we know that when Donald Trump took
Teresa's Mays hand at the White House he
really was walking her down the garden
path you know at that point people said
Oh
Britain's gone to the front of the queue
for a trade deal last week we heard that
actually we're not at the front of the
queue at all we've now gone to the back
of the queue behind the European Union
and it has already taken four years to
try and fail to negotiate the TTIP
agreement which is between the European
Union and the United States so the idea
that we are at the front of the queue
has now gone not only that we heard
resumes saying that she would be quite
relaxed about opening up our health
services to big American health care
companies now that is you know this is
something that people really
to understand the way in which our
country will change as a result of our
change in trade policy is dramatic they
need to understand that at all levels
and if you look at what's happened just
two days ago and in the European Union
the leaked document from the Commission
showed that they were now encouraging
European companies encouraging them to
discriminate against British companies
in tenders for European work now where
was the government where was Teresa me
she was out electioneering it was the
Labour Party that had to send a
complaint about the European Commission
to the European Ombudsman the Commission
is supposed to be the guardian of the
treaty the treaty says that if you're a
member state you cannot discriminate
against any member state and the
commission's supposed to guarantee that
they fail to do it but this government
completely failed to notice did nothing
about it and it took for me to put that
complaint into the Ombudsman because the
government has lost its eye on the main
deal about brexit the government is now
looking simply to the election and we're
in the midst of a two-year fixed period
of negotiation and Theresa May has taken
two years out that is arrogant quick for
every firm and it's also reckless in
terms of the negotiation a quick thought
from you on tax as well clearly it going
to be a huge issue on this election John
McDonnell seem to suggest that if you're
on 70,000 pounds or more then you're
rich you could be paying more tax do you
agree with him
look and members of parliament are in
that bracket 70,000 pounds you're in the
top five percent of the population say
alright let let lets let's understand
that the average wage in this country
has gone down in real terms by 10
percent
since 2007 okay so actually what we're
talking about is a 10 pound minimum wage
for all those 5.6 million people at the
bottom of the
of the pile and that will actually boost
our economy because those people tend to
spend their income more and yes I do
believe that people at the top and
certainly big companies should be paying
more tax and the way we'll do that is
because we've pledged to make those very
large companies have to publish their
tax returns to show that they're paying
exactly what tax they need to now before
you go so we haven't got too long okay
I'm going to ask you can I also just say
and our late payment policy which says
that big companies will have to stop
Bank it using small companies as their
backers they'll have to pay up in time
instead now three or four months now
you've been important for a long time
now couple of decades perhaps haven't
quite experienced anything like what you
saw this week after you gave us
particularly feisty set of interviews
you were described as the chuckling
assassin if the people don't shuffle
didn't this is one of your fans on
Twitter we can have a look at one
particular Twitter post here from smarty
see I love badass bars is this the
beginning of Baz mania yeah I've always
said that um I prefer policy to politics
and and and and very often we get into
personality politics I don't believe in
that and I think actually what's wrong
with a lot of the way in which the polls
and the newspapers conduct things is
that they go you know who's who's up or
who's down in the personality context i
I think we need to fight this election
on policies and on that basis I think we
should go in Fast mania is over you
heard it here first
Barry Gardiner thank you very much for
that what